AND HELPING UKRAINE FIGHT FOR
THEIR OWN FREEDOM.
>> BIDEN CAN'T LEAD THE UNITED
STATES.
WHEN I HEAR PRESIDENT BIDEN
BEING TOLD YOU NEED TO LEAVE TH
WORLD, FIRST OF ALL, WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY, HE'S OBVIOUSLY
INCREDIBLY HEROIC.
HE IS FIGHTING FOR HIS COUNTRY
AS HE SHOULD, BUT WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT WHO AS I SAID ON THE
ANGLE IS ESSENTIALLY A HOLOGRAM.
HE IS NOT AN ACTIVE PRESIDENT
DEFENDING OUR INTEREST HERE, LE
ALONE THE PRESIDENT OF THE WORLD
.
I THINK GOING DOWN THAT ROAD IS
KIND OF RIDICULOUS AT THIS POINT
.
>> WHAT HE COULD DO IS JUST STO
ENGAGING AND HALF MEASURES THAT
ARE A DAY LATE AND A DOLLAR
SHORT BREAK LAST WEEK HE CAME I
AND GAVE HST SPEECH ABOUT HOW W
WERE GOING TO BAN THE IMPORT OF
OIL INTO AMERICA, WE ARE STILL
IMPORTING RUSSIAN OIL.
THEY HAD A MONTH AND A HALF LON
LINE DOWN HERE AND WE'RE SENDIN
ON AVERAGE 20 MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS A DAY TO RUSSIA'S WAR
MACHINE.
THIS GOES BACK FOR MONTHS, YOU
HAVE PRESIDENT BIDEN WHO HAS
CONTINUALLY BEEN A DAY LATE AND
A DOLLAR SHORT, WHETHER DRAGGED
ALONG BY THE BRAVERY AND THE
COLLEGE DATE UKRAINIAN ARMY HAS
DISPLAYED AND FRANKLY BY MEMBER
OF CONGRESS AND BOTH PARTIES,
TODAY THEY ANNOUNCED THEY
TRANSFER OF $800 MILLION OF
WEAPONS TO UKRAINE, ITS WELCOME
BUT SHOULD'VE BEEN DONE A MONTH
OR TWO AGO AND IT'S JUST A
FRACTION OF WHAT CONGRESS
PROPOSED LAST WEEK.
THEY HAVE PROVEN THEY ARE
CAPABLE OF FIGHTING THE RUSSIAN
AND WE NEED TO ENCOURAGE THEM T
DO SO AND WE NEED TO PROVIDE
THEM THE WEAPONS THEY NEED TO
FIGHT THE RUSSIANS.
YOU DON'T THINK WE'RE GIVING TH
UKRAINIANS AT THIS POINT IN THE
REST OF THE WORLD FALL SO?
YOU THINK GIVEN THE FACT THAT
RUSSIA IS CLOSING IN ON UKRAINE
AT THIS MOMENT, WE HEARD THE AI
RAID SIRENS OUTSIDE OF, THAT WE
ARE NOT BUILDING PEOPLE UP WITH
FALSE HOPE AT THIS POINT?
I AM AFRAID OF THAT.
I AM WORRIED.
>> I REALLY DON'T.
WITH YOUR HEARING AIR RAIDS IS
THAT THE RUSSIAN ARMY HAS FAILE
IN ITS FIRST PLAN TO ENCIRCLE
THE CITY'S ENFORCER CAPITULATION
.
KYIV IS BEING HIT WITH MUSCLES
AND ARTILLERY.
THEY'RE ARE NO CLOSER TODAY THA
THEY WERE.
YES, THERE IS STILL A LOT OF
BLOODSHED IN RUSSIA.
RUSSIA IS STILL IN
INDISCRIMINATE BOMBING OF
CIVILIAN AREAS, THAT IS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE NOT ACHIEVE THE
MILITARY OBJECTIVES.
WE PROVIDED THEM NOT ONLY WITH
MIGS, BUT WITH THE KIND OF
ANTIMISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEMS AND
ANTI- AIRCRAFT SYSTEMS THEY ARE
PLEADING FOR, THEY COULD CLOSE
THEIR OWN SKIES, LAURA.
>> AND YOU THINK AT THIS POINT
PEACE NEGOTIATIONS, WHICH I SAI
ON THE ANGLE, IT SEEMS LIKE YOU
DON'T HEAR ANYBODY, NOT MANY IN
THE SENATE AND CERTAINLY NOT
BIDEN REALLY INDICATING THERE I
MUCH INTEREST IN HAVING TO STOP
TONIGHT LIKE COME TO AN END, TH
FOCUS IS GETTING THAT MIGS ARE
GETTING THE MISSILES, A BILLION
DOLLARS HERE A BILLION DOLLARS
THERE, BUT IT SEEMS LIKE THEY
ARE CLOSE TO AN AGREEMENT AT
THIS POINT WOULD YOU BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT?
>> I WOULD WELCOME A PEACE
AGREEMENT THAT STOPS THE
BLOODSHED IN UKRAINE.
IT'S NOT REALLY FOR US TO
NEGOTIATE THAT OR CERTAINLY TO
IMPOSE IT UPON THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE BIRD THAT'S A CHOICE FOR
THEM TO MAKE AN A DECISION MADE
BY PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY.
I DON'T THINK AMERICANS, WHETHE
THEY ARE IN CONGRESS OR IN THIS
MINISTRATION SHOULD DICTATE
THOSE TERMS.
AT PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
REPRESENTING THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE THAT'S ONE REASON HE
NEEDS THESE WEAPONS TO STOP THE
BLOODSHED AND PRESERVES
UKRAINE'S FREEDOM.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE A WELCOME
DEVELOPMENT, NOT ONL